[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend in ein an einem tag an dem
die omikron variante die zahl der korona
infektion auf neue rekordstände treibt
in deutschland müssen wir wieder mit der
tatsache klar kommen und umgehen dass
diese pandemie keine absoluten
gewissheiten kennt der schnelltest
gehört ja praktisch schon zum alltag bei
uns als mittel der wahl um den weg des
virus zu erkennen um zusätzliche
sicherheit zu haben bei treffen mit
freunden mit den eltern mit den
großeltern
umso verstörender sind grundlegende
zweifel an dieser zusätzlichen
sicherheit die gerade zu nehmen bei
denen nämlich bei denen ein schnelltest
nach dem anderen negativ ausfällt und
die dann feststellen dass sie dennoch
die ganze zeit infiziert sind laura
panik schaut auf das problem und seine
hintergründe
fast jeder hat inzwischen bekanntschaft
mit antigen schnelltests gemacht auch
heute stehen wieder viele leute wie hier
in mainz bei tests zentren an 100
prozent vertrauen in die tests haben
weniger also ich finde weil ich mich
essen gehen möchte und danach nicht viel
sicher habe ich schon mal erfahren mit
meinen schwager wird im monat und er
hatte schon mit pcr wo das als positiv
arbeiter hatte zwei tage vorher ein
antigen test sondern war negativ die
verunsicherung scheint berechtigt aber
wirken die anti gen tests wirklich
schlechter bei uniqa es ist so dass sich
das virus dann nochmal genetisch
verändert hat im vergleich zum delta
virus und auch die region oder das
protein was bei diesem antiken test
eigene detektiert wird hat eine
veränderung da ist eine lücke entstanden
sozusagen bionicon entscheidend für die
wirksamkeit ist wie gut der antigen test
das virus erkennen kann der schnell
testet bei dem sogenannten nucleus kz
protein kurz m protein an wenn die
antikörper vom test sich nach einer
mutter zu nicht mehr mit den proteinen
verbinden können kommt es zu einem
falschen ergebnis
das scheint aber nur wenige tests zu
betreffen aufgrund seiner schnellen er
die plätze und leichten handhabung ist
der anti gen test nach wie vor geeignet
um die breite masse zu testen allerdings
benötigt man eine vergleichsweise hohe
viruslast um eine infektion überhaupt
anzeigen zu können die sensitivität also
treffsicherheit ist geringer als bei pcr
tests gerade bei gemusterten und
geimpften kann die hohe erforderliche
viruslast zusätzlich das ergebnis
verfälschen denn eben diese virus last
ist nach einer impfung aufgrund des
wirksamen impfschutzes besonders niedrig
dadurch könnte das virus bei einem
einmaligen test trotz infektionen nicht
erfasst werden je öfter man testet umso
größer ist die wahrscheinlichkeit im
laufe der infektion eine ausreichende
virus menge zu erwischen bei aller
fehleranfälligkeit geht das
paul-ehrlich-institut dennoch aufgrund
bisheriger daten davon aus dass die
meisten anti gen tests in deutschland
auch omikron bei allen zuverlässig
nachweisen dass testen weg zu lassen
wäre ein fehler das ziel der anti gen
tests ist es personen mit vor virus las
zu erkennen die ein risiko für
kontaktpersonen haben und virus auf
diese kontaktpersonen übertragen könnten
und dieses ziel ist weiterhin gesichert
die bundesregierung lässt derzeit
überprüfen welche antigen schnelltests
auch bei omikron besonders zuverlässig
funktionieren experten aus den usa
weisen zudem darauf hin dass es bei
omikron eine rolle spielen könnte wo der
abstrich gemacht wird
laut einer neuen studie kann man mit
einem zusätzlichen rachenabstrich eine
infektion einen ganzen tag früher
feststellen als nur in der nase dort
scheint die infektion erst bei einer
höheren viruslast messbar zu sein
zusätzliche rachenabstriche mehrfache
testungen pro woche und schnelltests die
omikron am zuverlässigsten erkennen
können die messbarkeit des virus weiter
verbessern dazu sind aber weitere
studien und die liste der
funktionierenden schnelltests
erforderlich die das paul ehrlich
institut in den kommenden wochen
vorlegen will
während die fragen also drängender
werden wie zuverlässig schnelltests
überhaupt noch sind will die
bundesregierung sieht deutlich stärker
nutzen künftig soll man sich auch mit
antigenen schnell vorzeitig frei testen
können aus einer quarantäne und nicht
mehr nur mit pcr tests die regierung
verlangt dafür hochwertige antigen
schnelltests unklar bleibt welche das
genau sind
viele fragen heute auch im parlament
zunächst die wer von den abgeordneten
wegen corona künftig wo zu sitzen hat
dann die erste befragung des neuen
kanzlers bei der olaf scholz sich
vornahm zunächst mal höflich zu
reagieren schönen dank für ihre frage
ist sein meistbenutzte satz david
gebhard berichtet ein test zertifikat in
der hand ein kleines gefaltetes pub
schildchen irgendwo versteckt das von
afg abgeordneten in den plenarsaal
geschmuggelt wird doch dazu später ab
heute gilt unten im saal 2 g + wer weder
geimpft noch genießen ist kann mit test
oben auf der besuchertribüne platz und
teilnehmen ganz dort oben wo sie von
anderen abgeordneten nicht gesehen
werden sie halten also praktisch saal
verbot werden von der gemeinschaft alle
abgeordneten abgetrennt und so
schikaniert bei jedem restaurant besuch
gilt zweig plus und wir tun hier als
wäre es im deutschen bundestag nicht
notwendig von jedem schulkind in
deutschland erwarten wir dass es sich
testen lässt und sie und sie vergessen
hier krokodilstränen
als bundeskanzler olaf scholz gerade zu
reden begonnen hat schlägt die stunde
der abschied eine aktion die dem
parlamentarischen geschäftsführer der
afg ganz vorne der selbst kein schild
hat irgendwie peinlich zu sein scheint
alles verweisen ich behalte mir auch vor
ein entsprechendes ordnungsgeld für die
ganze fraktion im zweifel zu verhängen
im zweiten anlauf klappt sie dann die
erste befragung des kanzlers beobachtet
von neuen plätzen aus per ampel mehrheit
nach rechts versetzt sucht die union
ihre rolle als opposition mit sich
belauern den rivalen bald parteichef
märz und noch fraktionschef trinkaus
überlassen es heute anderen dem kanzler
führungsschwäche vorzuwerfen etwa über
die impfpflicht bei der scholz keine
sichere mehrheit
ich weiß
wenn der bundeskanzler in der größten
krise unserer zeit sagt das ist der weg
aus der krise dann muss der
bundeskanzler und seine regierung doch
einen vorschlag einen
gesetzgebungsvorschlag dafür
unterbreiten doch scholz beharrt auf der
so genannten
gewissensentscheidung wenn wir eine
impfpflicht festsetzen betrifft das
jeden einzelnen bürgern und bürger jede
bürgerin jeden bürger geht es um unsere
körper die wir alle haben und deshalb
ist es genau ein solcher fall wo man
diesen weg gehen soll bis zur
entscheidung über die impfpflicht setzt
scholz weiter auf massives impfen und
boostern was aus der afd grundsätzlich
in frage gestellt wird es sind 26.000
196 fälle schwerer nebenwirkungen laut
paul ehrlich institut bis ende november
60 millionen bürgern und bürger dieses
landes sind doppelt geimpft es ist gut
gegangen es hat ihnen genutzt und
natürlich weiß jeder dass es auch
nebenwirkungen geben kann darüber es
immer informiert worden und deshalb
halten sie sich an die fakten verwirren
sie nicht die bürger neben corona geht
es etwa auch um aussenpolitik um
autobahnbrücken und bildung es ist ein
altes muster in neuen rollen ihr
gefällige fragen der koalitionsparteien
scharmützel mit der opposition ungefähr
eine halbe millionen
sozialversicherungspflichtige jobs sind
in mini jobs umgewandelt worden und ich
frage sie nochmal wie wollen sie das
verhindern wenn sie jetzt die minijob
regelung ausweiten stimmt nicht was sie
so sagen darf man muss manchmal einfach
eine statistik angucken und kann
flugblatt das ist dann glaube ich die
bessere form sich zu informieren 15
fragen 15 nachfragen für die sich scholz
artig bedankt und die er dann oft
weniger beantwortet als abtropfen lässt
es war ein neuer kanzler ein neuer stil
war es nicht
und dann ist uns heute in der redaktion
eine pressekonferenz nicht mehr aus dem
kopf gegangen auf der die polizei in
köln bilanz zog das klingt jetzt erstmal
sehr routiniert und technisch es war
alles andere als das die ermittlungen im
sogenannten missbrauchs komplex bergisch
gladbach vor gut zwei jahren ins rollen
gekommen durch die festnahme eines
vaters der seine kleine tochter über
viele monate sexuell gequält und
vergewaltigt hatte am ende standen 65
kinder die aus der gewalt ihrer peiniger
befreit werden konnten bundesweit
hunderte tatverdächtige
und eine gruppe von routinierten
ermittlern den all das zugesetzt hat die
zu viel sehen mussten denen heute die
stimme stockt wenn sie davon berichten
in mehr als 40 dienstjahren habe ich sie
sicherlich sehr viel leid gesehen und
ungewöhnliche und schlimme verfahren
aber das was wir hier aufgedeckt haben
das sprengt alle maßstäbe deswegen sage
ich ausdrücklich heute ist kein grund
zum feiern
trotz der
65 betreuten kinder und der vielen
tatverdächtigen die wir ermitteln
konnten
die kinder waren von unter 1 jahren bis
17 jahre alt das jüngste opfer war
gerade mal drei monate und wurde von
seinen peinigern vergewaltigt
und doch kaum mag man das glauben haben
die kinder nach ihrem festgenommenen
missbrauchen geweint
werden ein opfer was von ihrem onkel
schwerstens missbraucht worden ist über
einen längeren zeitraum und dieses
mädchen war bei uns zu vernehmungen und
hatte dabei immer ein stofftier dabei
wir haben dann auch mal gefragt was das
5 stoff de ist wo das herkommt und waren
alle sehr entsetzt als wir dann gehört
haben dass genau dieses stofftier von
der person stammt von ihrem geliebten
onkel der sie so schwer missbraucht hat
wir haben tatverdächtige aus allen
gesellschaftsschichten
gutverdiener hoch
gebildete leute also folgen schulischen
und ausbildungsstand her sind einfache
leute dabei gewesen die aber trotzdem
dann ein ganz normales leben geführt
haben von außen nicht zu erkennen
ich halte das für enorm wichtig die
gesellschaft aufzurütteln deutlich zu
machen wir dürfen hier nicht wegschauen
wir machen weiter damit wir uns da
überhaupt nicht falsch verstehen und es
besteht leider auch kein großer anlass
dazu
sie wollten aufrütteln dort gewerbe hat
die stimmen der ermittler zusammen
gestellt
und hanna hat jetzt einen ersten
überblick über das was heute auch noch
sehr wichtig war
in der diskussion rund um eine mögliche
allgemeine impfpflicht hat
bundespräsident steinmeier eine
sorgfältige abwägung der argumente
angemahnt und einen respektvollen umgang
miteinander
impfpflicht bedeutet debatten pflicht
sagte steinmeier bei einer
diskussionsrunde zu der neben experten
auch befürworter und gegner einer
impfpflicht eingeladen waren steinmeier
selbst betonte sich persönlich nicht zu
positionieren aus respekt vor dem
anstehenden politischen prozess
einzelhändler die ihre geschäfte corona
bedingt schließen müssen können ihre
mietzahlungen unter umständen verringern
das gilt allerdings nicht pauschal
sondern nur nach vorheriger
einzelfallprüfung so entschied nun der
bundesgerichtshof in karlsruhe
betroffene händler müssen zum beispiel
die umsatzeinbußen am jeweiligen
standort offenlegen genauso wie
staatliche hilfen und
versicherungsleistungen
der einsatz deutscher soldatinnen und
soldaten im irak soll um neun monate
verlängert werden bis ende oktober
das entschied heute das bundeskabinett
die obergrenze von 500 soldaten soll
beibehalten werden diese werden unter
anderem zur beratung irakischer
sicherheitskräfte gebraucht und werden
außerdem im rahmen der anti es koalition
eingesetzt vor allem letzteres hatten
die grünen bisher kritisch gesehen der
bundestag muss der mandatsverlängerung
noch zustimmen
der facebook konzern meter muss sich in
den usa einem kartellverfahren stellen
einem monolog monopol klage der us
wettbewerbshüter wurde im zweiten anlauf
angenommen neben facebook gehören auch
instagram und whatsapp zu dem konzern
und genau das ist der kartellbehörde ein
dorn im auge facebook habe die beiden
plattformen gekauft um seine
monopolstellung zu schützen kritisieren
die wettbewerbshüter und fordern deren
verkauf das gerichtsverfahren wird
voraussichtlich mehrere jahre dauern
das ist ein kritischer moment für die
europäische sicherheit sagt der
nato-chef die lage bezüglich der
europäischen sicherheit hat eine
kritische linie erreicht sagt der kreml
beide seiten klingen da sehr ähnlich
aber sie meinen jeweils etwas komplett
anderes und das ist bereits das problem
der so genannte nato russland rat tagt
und zwar nicht in relaxter atmosphäre
sondern vor dem hintergrund einer
düsteren drohkulisse die wladimir putin
aufgefahren hat mit soldaten und
kriegsgerät an der grenze zur ukraine
dazu liegt ein russisches papier auf dem
tisch das im endeffekt europa wieder neu
aufteilen würde in russische und
amerikanische
einflusssphären die osteuropäer sind da
natürlich noch mal besonders alarmiert
sie sorgen sich bereits die gespräche
könnten putin in die hände spielen auf
der anderen seite droht ohne gespräche
eine neue eskalation die niemand wollen
sollte eine gellinek berichtet die
russen sind da seit zweieinhalb jahren
zum ersten mal im neuen nato
hauptquartier alexander gruschko ist ein
alter bekannter von 2012 bis 18 war er
ständiger vertreter russlands bei der
militärallianz ein harter knochen weiß
die nato
auch die amerikaner haben keine
anfängerin geschickt us top diplomat in
windy sherman ist ebenfalls mit allen
wassern gewaschen die begrüßung
freundlich aber als die türen zu sind
weht ein hauch von kaltem krieg durch
den saal russland will die zeit
zurückdrehen verlangt einen rückbau der
nato auf den zustand von 1997 also bevor
die östlichen mitgliedsländer eins nach
dem anderen dem westlichen bündnis
beitraten in der nato osterweiterung
sieht alexander gruschko auch nach dem
treffen die ursache allen übels die
politik der offenen türen muss gestoppt
werden das ist für uns ein absolutes
muss russland braucht binden der
garantien dass die nato sich nicht
weiter nach osten ausdehnt
das aber ist für 30 nato-länder im saal
nicht verhandelbar russland scheint das
bündnis zusammengeschweißt zu haben neue
und alte mitglieder sprechen mit einer
stimmung
generalsekretär stoltenberg schlägt vor
man könnte ja wenigstens über
vertrauensbildende maßnahmen reden
rüstungskontrolle sich gegenseitig über
truppenbewegungen und übungen
informieren russland zögert noch
russland waren nicht in der lage diesem
vorschlag heute zuzustimmen aber sie
haben ihn auch nicht abgelehnt sie haben
gesagt dass sie noch etwas zeit brauchen
die amerikanische unterhändlerin ist da
weniger diplomatisch
sein russland den dialog aus schlägt
dann ist klar dass sie den
diplomatischen weg nie ernsthaft wollten
doch soweit ist es noch nicht inhaltlich
trennen nato und russland welten
russlands truppen stehen weiter an der
ukrainischen grenze und doch sagen alle
selbst der grimmige herr gruschko dass
das gespräch im nato-russland-rat
nützlich war ich erinnere mich nicht
daran dass wir je eine so direkte und
auch scharfe diskussion hatten und
gleichzeitig ein so intimes gespräch
ein nato russland rat nach zwei jahren
pause er könnte ein anfang gewesen sein
oder auch ein ende russland muss
entscheiden
der nato-generalsekretär ist bei uns ich
grüße sie herr stoltenberg
sie kommen gerade aus den gesprächen mit
russland haben gesagt die waren not easy
wie hat man sich denn die jetzt
vorzustellen redet da jede seite erst
mal jeweils eine halbe stunde und wirft
dann der anderen in langen tiraden vor
was sie falsch gemacht habe
die gespräche sind nicht einfach aber
sie waren offen und wurden frei gefühlt
und das ist ein gutes zeichen dass die
nato verbündeten und russland jetzt
wieder am selben tisch sitzen können
bunte substanzielle fragen ansprechen
können denn wer muss ne weile nicht
gesehen mehr zwei jahre in die im
nato-russland-rat
dass die gespräche nicht einfach sind
heißt nicht dass sie nicht sehr wichtig
wären das ist ein wichtiges meeting
heute in werden deutlich gemacht dass
wir uns auf ganz ernsthafte fragen
konzentrieren wollen beide seite im
interesse und dann hoffen wir dass da
eine positive reaktion kommt und ein
kontinuierlicher dialog
wenn sie auf diesen tag zurück gucken
empfinden sie russland als partner oder
als gegner
die welt ist vielschichtiger das kann
man so nicht sehen wir erleben ein
aggressiveres russland ein russland das
bereitschaft gezeigt hat in der
vergangenheit militärische gewalt
einzusetzen gegen nachbarstaaten in der
vergangenheit gegen georgien jetzt eben
auch gegen die ukraine und das ist schon
sehr schwerwiegend wir erleben einen
militärischen aufbau seitens russland
mit
zig tausend soldaten mit schweren waffen
modernsten waffen systemen kombiniert
mit einer sehr aggressiven rhetorik und
dann natürlich die vergangenheit was
russland dort unternommen hat gegen
seinen nachbarn wir rufen sie auch zu
deeskalieren sagen aber auch deutlich
wenn ihr noch einmal gewalt einsetzt
gegen die ukraine dann wird das schwere
wirtschaftliche und politische
konsequenzen haben
wir hoffen dass sie den dialog
akzeptieren
sie haben die situation gerade noch mal
beschrieben wissen sie denn überhaupt
war es wladimir putin vor hat
eine gewissheit bezüglich intentionen
aber wir sehen hier die fakten
da werden zusammengezogen
blicken auf die vergangenheit und haben
genug grund beunruhigt zu sein aber
gleichzeitig tun wir was wir tun können
auf unserer seite um deutlich zu machen
dass alles hat seinen preis wenn das so
weitergeht
wir tun was wir können und sie
abzuhalten von einsatz von gewalt die
nato verbündeten haben der ukraine auch
unterstützung zugesagt sie helfen dem
land auch seinen grund recht auf
selbstbestimmung und selbstverteidigung
auszuhöhlen und wir helfen ihnen und
heben damit auch wiederum die stelle an
für einen militäreinsatz den ukraine und
dann müssen wir natürlich sicherstellen
dass es hier keine missverständnisse
bezüglich der bereitschaft der nato
auch irgendwelche angriffe gegen
irgendein verbündeten zu sanktionieren
da denkt ja auch ein dicker und lettland
also sie entwickeln hier gerade quasi
eine strategie ohne dass sie wirklich
wissen was das gegenüber tatsächlich
vorhat jetzt ist einmal doch auch
aktuell ja völlig offen wie so eine
einigung aussehen soll für die nato
haben sie mehrfach jetzt gesagt sind die
russischen forderungen nicht akzeptabel
umgekehrt was die nato anbietet das
stellt russland nicht zufrieden also wie
soll es denn jetzt weiter gehen
eine solche diplomatie kammer nicht in
der öffentlichkeit betreiben da müssen
wir direkt direkten gespräche führen mit
den involvierten ländern und deswegen
begrüße ich diesen heutigen tag so sehr
und deswegen schlagen wir ein prozess in
die zukunft vor wir haben deutlich
gemacht wir sind gesprächsbereit bereit
über viele auch zum beispiel
rüstungskontrolle viele themen zu denen
eine beiderseits ausgewogen reduzierung
sowohl der taktischen als auch der
konventionelle waffen dazu ist die nato
bereit
und den ganz gewiss dass das auch so
weitergehen wird aber wir sind auch zu
kompromissen bereit darum geht es ja
letztlich bei dieser ausgewogenheit in
der rüstungskontrolle
aber wir sind nicht bereit zu
kompromissen
im kern prinzipien der europäischen
sicherheit ohne das ist zumindest mal
das recht jedes landes seinen weg zu
definieren unabhängig von sicherheit
sicherheitsvorkehrungen sollten noch
stehen die nato länder eng beisammen
aber über die nächsten schritte da kamen
schon einiges an uneinigkeit spüren die
osteuropäer insbesondere haben große
angst dass es zu viele zugeständnisse
geben könnte an wladimir putin und wenn
wir jetzt mal bei auf uns hier in
deutschland gucken da hört man aus der
spd auch vom bundeskanzler die pipeline
nord stream 2 zum beispiel sei rein
wirtschaftlich zu betrachten das klingt
jetzt nicht unbedingt so als ob da viele
sanktions masse aus deutscher sicht mit
im spiel sein könnte können sie sich
denn vorstellen mal ganz konkret gefragt
dass so eine pipeline aus russland in
betrieb geht unter diesen umständen
ansichten bezüglich dem 2 unter den
bündnispartnern aber sie sind alle einig
bezüglich der notwendigkeit
auch die versorgungs diese
diversifizierung in energiefragen
sicherzustellen klar wir sind 30
verschiedene bündnispartner auf beiden
seiten des atlantiks unterschiedliche
geschichte unterschiedliche schwerpunkte
da sind riesen unterschiede das ist aber
ein zeichen der stärke und der schwäche
dass wir 30 demokratien sind aber
da stehen zusammen bezüglich deren
botschaft oder der gern verpflichtungen
wir sind bereit einander zu schützen und
zu verteidigen
mögliche gegner die antwort kommt von
allen bündnispartnern alle für einen und
einer für alle das ist der grundsatz der
nato und solange uns das gelingt und wir
so auftreten kommen waren wir den
frieden verhinderte konflikte und stellt
sicher dass alle sicherheit bin ich
danke sicher sei sowie die nato ist seit
mehr als 70 jahren tut die botschaft
heute aus dem nato hauptquartier in
brüssel ihren stoltenberg herzlichen
dank
danke für
das gespräch aber aus termingründen vor
der sendung aufgezeichnet und hanna
macht jetzt hier weiter mit der
wirtschaft und einer nachricht die ja
alle häuslebauer umtreiben wird die
baupreise sind ja sowieso schon
gestiegen jetzt könnten auch noch die
bauzinsen teurer werden hintergrund ist
eine forderung der finanzaufsicht bafin
habe nach bei valerie haller an der
frankfurter börse was könnte da auf all
diejenigen zu kommen die von den eigenen
vier wänden träumen und warum also der
kauf einer wohnimmobilie könnte etwas
schwieriger oder auch und auch teurer
werden hintergrund ist dass den
finanzaufsehern der boom am
immobilienmarkt langsam unheimlich wird
wenn da eine blase platzt könnte das zum
problem für banken werden die
finanzaufseher wollen ihnen nun
vorschreiben besser vorzusorgen kosten
die banken möglicherweise an ihre kunden
weitergeben vielleicht in form höherer
bauzinsen die korona pandemie hat den
buben am wohnimmobilienmarkt kaum
gebremst im gegenteil sie hat ihn weiter
befeuert besonders in metropolen droht
der markt heiß zu laufen
laut bundesbank gibt es wohnimmobilien
kredite über mehr als 1,6 billionen euro
die preise für wohnimmobilien lägen zehn
bis 30 prozent über den werten die sich
durch etwa marktanalysen rechtfertigen
lassen tatsächlich sind die preise im
dritten quartal noch mal um zwölf
prozent gestiegen ein risiko auch für
banken die viele immobilien kredite
vergeben haben und noch vergeben die
finanzaufsicht verlangt von den banken
nun mehr geld für den krisenfall zur
seite zu legen die deutsche
kreditwirtschaft kritisiert den plan sie
befürchtet dass banken dadurch in ihrer
kreditvergabe eingeschränkt werden
können für die bafin aber ein
notwendiger schritt die banken seien
verwundbarer geworden vielen dank
valerie nach frankfurt
der begriff push back es zum unwort des
jahres 2021 gewählt worden das teilte
die jury aus sprachwissenschaftlern
innen und sprachwissenschaftlern mit der
ausdruck bezeichnet das zum teil
gewaltsame zurückdrängen von
flüchtlingen an grenzen die jury
kritisiert den begriff da er einen
menschenfeindlichen prozess beschönige
die gewalt die damit verbunden sei würde
mit dem ausdruck verschleiert
der einsatz synthetischer
pflanzenschutzmittel hat weltweit einen
neuen höchstwert erreicht das geht aus
dem neuen pestizid atlas der heinrich
böll stiftung und der umweltorganisation
bnd hervor die jährlich versprühte menge
an pestiziden liege mehr als 80 prozent
über dem wert von 1990
am häufigsten werden äpfel weinreben und
kartoffeln gespritzt die
pflanzenschutzmittel sind eine gefahr
für das ökosystem und führen zum verlust
der artenvielfalt kritisiert der bericht
und jetzt noch die zahlen vom lotto sie
lauten 10 16 32 33 38 48 und die
superzahl 4 alle angaben ohne gewähr
viel glück und wir empfehlen ihnen jetzt
das auslandsjournal natürlich direkt
nach uns unter anderem mit einem
spannenden reportagen über den fall
novak djokovic
und gegen 0 uhr 30 meldet sich dann nach
sagte mir mit unserem heute-journal
update von uns allen hier an sie ein
angenehmer abend
[Musik]
guten abend und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter des wales gletscher ist einer der
wichtigsten in der westantarktis und
droht schneller zu zerbrechen als bisher
angenommen und misst etwa die hälfte der
fläche deutschlands
ein drittel besteht aus einer
vorgelagerten eisplatte dem sogenannten
schelfeis sie schwimmt auf dem meer und
dient als natürliche barriere für den
gletscher allerdings wirkt auch hier die
globale erhitzung denn das schelfeis
wird vom wärmeren mehr wasser unterspült
und schmilzt eine folge sind kilometer
lange risse die das abbrechen von
eisbergen zusätzlich begünstigt löst
sich aber die platte komplett droht der
ganze gletscher abzurutschen und das
führt zum meeresspiegelanstieg um 65
zentimeter bedroht ganze küstenstädte
und regionen in wenigen jahrzehnten
weltweit
forscher befürchten in der folge eine
kettenreaktion die benachbarte gletscher
nach rutschen lassen könnten
beim wetter arme ist auch mit etwas
schnee zu tun richtung erzgebirge und
auch regen kann dabei sein und dann für
glatte straßen sorgen im südwesten klart
es auf und vor allem an den alpen wird
es dann eisig kalt bis minus 11 grad
nach norden ist es eher frostfrei mit
fünf grad richtung schleswig holstein
morgen im südwesten dafür viel
sonnenschein und im nordosten dichte
bewölkung insgesamt trocken bei
temperaturen bis minus ein grad im
vogtland und 8 grad im norden die
nächsten tage gibt es nebel oder sonne
je nachdem was gewinnt bei 0 bis 8 grad
ein schöner abend